max what do you want for dinner
hello there batman fans issue three of
the caped crusaders adventures on the
fortnite island released
and like usual we're going to break down
everything that happened
in the third installment of the story
highlighting things you may have missed
and the super important things too
i'll be sure to link the playlist if
you've joined this series late my
creator code is adamaru if you fancy
supporting my nonsense
and as always a like goes a long way
towards helping me out
anyway back on point let's break down
issue three of
batman fortnite zero point
two weeks ago we watched batman and
catwoman team up to give selena the vic
roy
and hopefully escape the loop right away
this episode is a special one
look at those dialogue panels almost the
entire issue is written from the
perspective of a person
outside the loop watching batman on the
island
we aren't given details on who they are
i'm going to assume
it's an io employee but keep in mind
this isn't confirmed
just yet we pick up the story as batman
is beating the living hell out of all
the other combatants
and look there's my girl penny the
message reads
into office memo from loop observation
to
psyops subject i'm worried about the
batman
the message is sent by someone whose job
it is to watch
fortnite it'd be like watching twitch 24
hours a day
not a bad job but the thing which is
most interesting is who the memo
is to cyops siteops is a shorthand way
of
saying psychological operations this is
the process of changing people's
behavior to suit those
making the decisions a form of
manipulation
we won't delve into that that's a topic
for another time right now we know
someone is outside the loop
dictating what happens inside the loop
batman in this issue
is totally focused on escape by winning
the game and being the last person
standing
he continues to write notes to himself
on his armor and thanks to that
he makes a weapon to give himself an
unfair advantage
technically batman is using hacks right
now
[Music]
in every issue so far batman has cheated
first teaming with catwoman
and now using hacks to make his weapon
rp batman retains his emotions in
between rounds
and this is key to him being so driven
to win the person watching comments
it feels personal and in the following
panel the io official
asks if the emotional memories can be
wiped
this is followed up by saying that
immobilizing someone's feelings in the
loop
impacts their fighting ability their
skill their edge
noting that they have an agenda for
batman to follow
get this they want batman to escape the
loop but he's doing it too quickly and
may succeed before they're ready for him
batman is unbelievably efficient at
defeating enemies on the island
every storm circle he stays at the
center of it keep on running batman
a new memo pops up loop observation is
now speaking to
acquisitions those are responsible for
finding and recruiting assets
into fortnite and they have a solution
to slow down batman
a new asset joins the fight wielding a
katana and moving like a ninja
batman may have found his equal the
asset
is snake eyes
[Music]
as a brief history lesson snake eyes is
from the gi joe universe
who after saving a princess in peril is
given the name snake eyes and trained to
be a badass ninja
he's the first gaijin in the clan other
versions of his backstory see him
serving in the vietnam war he's a key
bit of law
snake eyes will feel quite at home on
the island because he cannot speak
he was shot in the throat in the
resolute storyline many years ago
remember that he's mute it comes up
later the observer knows how perfectly
matched batman and snake eyes are
perfect attacks are followed by perfect
blocks in a battle which lasts
the entire length of a loop 22 minutes
oh and a quick note that the run of
batman being smashed in the face
continues just like harley quinn last
episode snake eyes hits a headbutt which
would break most people's noses
but not bruce you know why because i'm
batman the fights are stopped by the
storm and every 22 minutes the battle
begins afresh
in a brand new loop something had to
change
batman tries to bring back an old
favorite vehicle do you remember its
name
yeah it's the quad crasher good little
easter egg there snake eyes and batman's
battles become so epic and huge
that all the other characters in game
completely stop fighting
and choose to watch these two titans
fight instead this page is full of
fortnite characters you'll recognize
what's super interesting is the
characters that don't belong to epic
games
in this issue in addition to batman's
snake eyes we can see
a fortnight psycho straight out of
borderlands
and here look at the shadowy outlines a
dual wielding character which looks a
lot like
deadpool a marvel character in a dc
comic book
deadpool was actually based on
deathstroke who will soon be part of
this story too
but the cameo which i'll probably put on
the thumbnail is here
do you recognize this silhouette i'd put
money on this being sama saran from the
metroid series
she never made it into fortnite at least
not yet
but we heard something via the apple vs
epic trial that samus was indeed planned
to join the fortnite world alongside
kratos representing playstation
and master chief representing xbox so
samus would have been there
representing nintendo sadly that was not
to be
but unofficially look she's here stood
next to capcom's street fighters ryu
and chun li there's a really good remote
to go with chun li you should try it
sometime
back to the story here's more law we
know that memories are wiped every
single loop
but emotions carry over over multiple
battles batman and snake eyes have
discovered
another emotion which carries over
respect
the two are now kindled into a bromance
that we haven't seen on the island for a
very long time they even share a moment
where they catch each other's throwables
like total bffs out of nowhere bruce is
blindsided by the oppressor
and to show us the bromance based on
fighting prowess is legit
snake eyes eliminates oppressor brutally
saving batman's life they share a moment
and straight back to fighting one
another
the battle takes the duo to the cliff
tops south of dirty docks
and a single mistake hands victory to
batman
snake eyes loses his footing at the edge
of the cliff
doomed to die from fall damage we've all
been there
but heck no batman catches the arm of
snake eyes preventing his fall
you son of a batman
had enough the person watching
looks like they've hit their face on the
keyboard right now and writes
auras which is quickly deleted from the
conversation
now here's a bombshell of information
remember in issue one when batman tried
to use sign language to talk to ruckus
that failed and also remember snake eyes
is mute
well take a look at this batman and
snake eyes
pause their fight for a moment to speak
to each other in
sign language a frantic email is sent by
the observer to
archives to try and decipher these hand
signals
both of these characters are american so
i'm going to assume they are using asl
american sign language
which means my limited knowledge of
british sign language may be useless
here
so i'm going to assume batman says this
if you do know what these gestures mean
please let me know and i'll pin your
comments below
snake eyes looks to be saying voice but
even the person observing
doesn't know the language they deduce
this sign language is used on multiple
worlds and dimensions
batman kinda looks like he's asking
snake eyes to leave the circle willingly
the panic of the observer now reaches
fever pitch as snake eyes
understands batman's theory and the two
share a bro moment
snake eyes walks into the storm to give
batman the vikroy
this moment is overshadowed by the memo
circulating around io
this time all senior partners are copied
in
things just got serious snake eyes looks
back
as batman shows his respect and
gratitude snake eyes is eliminated
bruce is now the sole survivor at the
center of the final circle
he will break out of the loop in a few
moments
the observer warns of batman's impending
arrival
and wishes those who will face him the
best of luck
batman did it he survived he is now out
of the loop but this adventure
is just about to change escaping the
22-minute loop
was the easy part batman looks up to
hear the first voice he's heard in weeks
don't do anything stupid catwoman is
being held hostage by deathstroke
who proclaims no sudden moves or she's
dead
to be continued in part four of the zero
point storyline
a few things to quickly note back in
issue one and the mysterious figure who
pushed batman into the void
we are now 100 certain it was
deathstroke
deathstroke somehow broke out of the
loop either by winning or maybe
something else we haven't considered yet
but the thing i was wondering all along
was if the island would change when
outside the loop
but judging from this first look the
island is the same
from this point forward batman and the
cast will have use of their voices again
and no longer be controlled by a wipe
every 22 minutes
but we don't know if they have their
memories back already or they'll regain
them over time
or maybe never so many questions about
the observer and how they knew he would
escape the loop here's my back
crazy guess midas rex i think he's the
key here
he broke the loop before so maybe he's
the mastermind at work
i can't wait to find out i'm adam from
playstation grenade here's a bunch of
legends who made this series possible by
using my code adamaru in the store
thank you so much i truly appreciate it
see you next time
[Music]
you